Manny: YouTube is arguably the
biggest and most influential
social-media platform in existence.
But gone are the days when YouTube's
primary export was funny cat videos.
Today, YouTube is the primary platform
for just about every topic of video,
from workout tutorials to
beauty-guru feuds and this.
Carlos Maza: There's a
lot of cool stuff in here,
but I am not an energy-policy expert,
so I have questions.
Steven Crowder: What were you
holding, gay Latino from Vox?
Manny: That's Steven Crowder,
a popular conservative YouTuber
making a name for himself on the platform.
That video was a rebuttal to this video
by Carlos Maza, a producer at Vox.
Maza: Trump had tweeted a bulls--- claim
that the Green New Deal would somehow ban
cars, cows, and the military.
How would you ban a cow?
Manny: While both
commentators are taking jabs
at the other side of the
aisle, the difference
between their language
couldn't be any clearer.
Crowder: This is what
Mr. Gay Vox wants to do.
Mr. Lispy Queer from Vox.
The gay Vox sprite is wrong.
Now, he could be a tranny, your honor.
Manny: In a viral tweet thread,
Maza complained to YouTube
about this harassment,
and it removed the videos
in question from the site,
underlining an effort to make sure
they're hosting a safe and inclusive
platform for creators.
I'm sorry, what?
YouTube actually did
the complete opposite.
YouTube responded to Maza by saying
that while it found
Crowder's language hurtful,
he did not violate its policies.
The question here is why not?
Does YouTube have a
responsibility to regulate this?
According to YouTube's
own harassment policy,
videos where Crowder
ridicules Maza for being gay
should be removed from
the site immediately.
If you look at the language
of YouTube's policy,
it says "hurtful" language
is a potential justification
for removing a video, and
YouTube literally used the word
"hurtful" to describe Crowder's content
in their first response to Maza.
As the story continued to gain traction,
YouTube issued a second response.
The site decided to remove
ads from Crowder's channel,
but it's a lousy
punishment for two reasons.
First, YouTube already
limits monetization on videos
about hot-button issues that
aren't deemed "brand safe,"
even when those videos come
from legitimate news outlets.
Secondly, Crowder doesn't just
make money from YouTube ads.
Under his videos, he includes
a link to his online store,
where you can buy shirts like this.
To make this punishment even weaker,
YouTube said it would
remonetize his channel
if he removed that link.
What is the point of punishing Crowder
for making hurtful content
if that content is still
available to the public?
This entire situation calls into question
YouTube's willingness to restrict accounts
that perform well for them.
Steven Crowder has millions of subscribers
and banks millions of
views with his videos.
Because of YouTube,
his influence is strong,
and his engagement is high.
Punishing him would limit his influence,
which in turn limits
YouTube's reach as a platform.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
YouTube might have started as just a tool
for content creators, but the company acts
as much more than that today.
It has an algorithm that
recommends and surfaces videos
that lots of people have already watched,
dictating what gets in front of eyeballs.
It's already doing things that influence
what people do and don't watch,
which means it's behaving
much more like a media company
than a simple publishing platform.
Nearly 500 hours of video are uploaded
to YouTube every minute, and we watch
1 billion hours of
YouTube content every day.
So yeah, the power is there,
but where is the responsibility?
In a blog post, YouTube
gave another reason
why it wouldn't remove Crowder's videos.
It says it's because
the point of the videos
wasn't to demean Carlos Maza.
This is confusing and
allows for other users
to say hurtful comments
with no repercussions,
under the guise that
those hurtful comments
aren't the purpose of the video.
YouTube says it's gonna
revisit its harassment policy,
but all signs point to Crowder's videos
remaining on the site.
By refusing to restrict Crowder's
homophobic and racist comments,
YouTube is inadvertently greenlighting
the use of this language in
other places on its platform.
I haven't even mentioned the
fact that Crowder's followers
went on to harass Maza for days.
This is not OK.
For a company whose influence
is growing exponentially,
they could be setting
a dangerous precedent.